In this lesson we'll talk about PowerBoost which is a traffic shaping
mechanism that was first deployed in commercial broadband
networks in June 2006 by Comcast. The PowerBoost allows
a subscriber to send at a higher rate for a
brief period of time. So if you subscribed at a rate of ten megabits per second,
then PowerBoost might allow you to send at a higher rate for some period of time
before being shaped back to the rate at which you were subscribed at. So,
PowerBoost targets the Spare Capacity in the
network for use by subscribers who don't put
a sustained load on the network. There are two types of PowerBoosts. If the rate
at which the user can achieve during this burst window is set to not exceed
a particular rate. Then we say that the policy is capped PowerBoost, otherwise
the policy, or the shaping, is called
uncapped PowerBoost. Now in the uncapped setting,
the configuration is simple and as we described in the last lesson. The area
here is the PowerBoost bucket size. That's the maximum amount
of traffic that can be sent that exceeds the sustained rate.
The maximum sustained traffic rate is simply Rho,
as we've defined it before. Now suppose that we wanted to cap the rate that
the sender could send during the power boost window. Well all we need to do
in that case is to simply apply a second token bucket with another value of
Rho. That token bucket limits the peak sending rate for Power Boost eligible
packets to the rate Rho C, where Rho C is larger than Rho. Remember
that this value of Rho also affects how quickly tokens can refill in the bucket,
so it also plays the role in the maximum
rate that can be sustained during a power boost window.